-Elle se définit
comme une salariée lambda,
une madame Tout-le-Monde,
fière de représenter
les Français à l'Assemblée.
Mon invitée revendique
son côté novice en politique.
Elle en fait même
sa marque de fabrique.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Ségolène Amiot.
-Bonjour.
-Alors, votre première
prise de parole
n'est pas passée inaperçue.
C'était après la déclaration
de l'ancienne secrétaire d'Etat
Caroline Cayeux,
qui avait voulu justifier
son hostilité
au mariage gay tout en se défendant
d'être homophobe.
On va revivre ça en images.
*-Je vais vous dire,
quand même,
que j'ai beaucoup d'amis
parmi tous ces gens-là,
et franchement,
c'est un mauvais procès
qu'on me fait,
et ça m'a beaucoup contrariée.
-Mme la ministre,
je suis de ces gens-là.
La liste des propos homophobes
est trop longue.
Béchu, Darmanin et bien sûr Cayeux,
qui affirme toujours
son mépris des homosexuels.
Je vous le rappelle au cas où,
chers ministres,
l'homophobie n'est pas une opinion,
c'est un délit.
*-BRAVO !
-On sent de l'émotion
dans votre voix,
ce jour-là.
Tout est parti
de l'expression "ces gens-là"
de Caroline Cayeux.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle porte en elle,
pour vous ?
-En fait,
au-delà de l'expression,
ça veut dire "ce sont des gens
qui ne sont pas moi",
et au-delà de ça,
ce qu'on entend souvent,
c'est "je ne suis pas raciste,
j'ai un ami noir",
"je ne suis pas homophobe,
"j'ai des amis gays".
-Ca vous a mise en colère ?
-Ouais, complètement,
de se dire
qu'on en est encore là en 2022,
à ce moment-là 2022,
mais on en est encore là
à se défendre
d'être homophobe
parce qu'on a des amis gays...
-Vous vous sentez ostracisée ?
-C'est pas tant moi
que le fait qu'on a encore
à apprendre ce que c'est
que d'être homophobe,
que ce n'est pas forcément
déclarer de la haine,
mais de faire une différence.
C'est pareil pour le racisme,
et toutes les discriminations.
-Vous dites
"je suis de ces gens-là",
vous appartenez
à la communauté LGBT.
Vous vous définissez
comme pansexuelle.
Je ne sais pas
si tout le monde sait
ce que ça veut dire.
-En quelques mots, "pansexuelle",
c'est que je n'ai pas d'attache
au corps des gens.
Ce qui va m'attirer chez quelqu'un,
c'est qui il ou elle est,
sans discrimination de son genre...
-Sans regarder le genre...
-Exactement.
Je tombe amoureuse de personnes
car elles sont belles à l'intérieur.
Homme ou femme.
-Ce jour-là, donc,
vous avez pris la parole
sur le sujet à l'origine
de votre engagement public,
vous avez été vice-présidente
du centre LGBT de Nantes.
Qu'est-ce qui a motivé
votre démarche ?
Pourquoi vous être engagée ?
-J'ai décidé de m'engager
car j'ai eu la chance
d'être accueillie par ce centre LGBT
au moment où je me posais
des questions
sur mon orientation sexuelle.
J'ai constaté
qu'il y avait besoin
de coups de main, tout simplement,
pour aller expliquer aux jeunes
ce qu'est la discrimination...
-Ce combat
que vous avez porté
dans l'hémicycle.
-Exactement.
-Est-ce que, vous-même,
vous aviez été victime
de discriminations ?
-J'ai été victime
de discriminations.
Au départ, par des petits mots,
des serveurs de café, ici, à Paris,
qui, parce que je venais
d'embrasser ma compagne,
nous demandent de sortir,
car c'est "un établissement
respectable",
donc, voilà, ce genre de choses,
jusqu'à vivre l'agression
d'une autre de mes compagnes
en plein centre-ville de Nantes,
et tout ce qu'on peut vivre
au quotidien
de "t'as pas rencontré
"le bon mec"
ou un médecin, même,
qui, du jour où je lui dis
que je n'ai plus besoin
de la pilule,
parce que je n'ai aucun risque
de tomber enceinte
avec une compagne,
commence à pratiquer
des examens douloureux,
voire incomplets,
pour me faire comprendre
qu'on n'est pas là
pour prendre du plaisir.
Donc, voilà, c'est à la fois
dans ma chair et dans mon quotidien,
de voir certains de mes amis
aller jusqu'au suicide,
parce que ce qu'ils vivaient
était beaucoup trop douloureux.
-Alors,
vous avez eu un engagement
avant la politique,
il était syndical.
Vous étiez employée
dans un centre d'appel téléphonique.
Vous avez été DP.
Vous avez défendu les salariés,
mais ça n'a pas suffi.
Vous dites : "La politique,
"je m'y suis intéressée
par obligation."
Ca veut dire quoi ?
-En fin de compte,
c'est au moment
de la réforme du code du travail...
-Ce qu'on a appelé
"la loi El Khomri".
-Exactement.
Comprendre
pourquoi on avait tout cassé,
et réaliser
que je n'avais plus les outils
pour défendre mes collègues,
pour porter des affaires...
-Et vous vous êtes dit...
-Je n'ai plus le choix.
Manifestement, je n'ai plus
les outils pour aider.
Le seul moyen
de faire changer les choses,
c'est de changer les lois.
Je me suis engagée
en tant que militante,
pas en tant que candidate,
je me suis engagée
pour aider une candidate,
en l'occurrence,
à devenir elle-même députée.
-Ca, c'est à peu près 2017.
Vous n'êtes pas candidate
au sein de La France Insoumise.
Puis vous vous présentez
en 2022.
Vous êtes élue députée,
vous, l'employée
d'un centre d'appel.
Vous êtes plusieurs
à représenter une France
qui n'avait pas sa place
dans l'hémicycle.
Est-ce que vous le ressentez
comme une responsabilité ?
Ca fait peser un poids
sur vos épaules ?
-En fait, au-delà d'un poids,
j'espère que ça va devenir
un étendard.
J'aimerais vraiment
que les jeunes de mon quartier,
que les femmes,
que les personnes...
...lambda, comme moi, intègrent
et acceptent
que la politique,
ça nous appartient aussi,
à toutes et tous,
et qu'il faut s'en saisir...
-Vous espérez
que ça donne envie à d'autres ?
-Je le souhaite,
et je milite pour ça,
que chacun s'approprie
les questions politiques.
-Vous parlez de salariée lambda,
de "madame Tout-le-Monde",
ou "noob" ?
-Noob !
-Ca veut dire quoi, ça ?
-C'est une expression de geek,
une expression de joueurs...
-De joueurs de jeux vidéo ?
-Exactement.
Ca veut dire
qu'on vient de commencer,
qu'on ne connaît pas...
On est débutant. On débute.
-Ce côté débutant, novice,
ça veut dire que vous avez
une méthode différente ?
-Je le pense,
dans le sens
où je n'ai pas les codes.
On est à l'Assemblée nationale,
il y a des codes,
des façons de faire, de se tenir,
de s'habiller, de se parler,
que je n'ai pas,
parce que je n'ai pas grandi
dans ce milieu.
-Ca se traduit comment,
dans votre action politique ?
-Parfois, j'enfonce des portes
que je ne devrais pas enfoncer.
Une des premières questions
que je me suis posée en arrivant,
et que j'ai posée à tous les gens
que j'ai pu rencontrer,
c'est
"On a le numéro de téléphone
"du ministre de l'Education ?"
-Ca a surpris, ça a choqué ?
Ca a quoi ?
-Oui, et on me disait :
"C'est pas comme ça
"qu'on fonctionne".
J'ai demandé à mon assistant
qui, le pauvre, était tout seul,
en plus,
pour m'aider à ce moment-là.
Elue depuis 2 jours !
Il s'est débrouillé,
il a réussi à le contacter.
-Vous avez pu agir
sur un dossier
avec vos méthodes ?
-Voilà.
-Est-ce qu'avec ce regard
totalement neuf sur la politique,
il y a des choses
qui vous ont choquée ?
-Oui. Déjà...
Le décorum.
Ce n'est pas uniquement le bâtiment
et le faste...
-C'est-à-dire ?
On le voit, un peu.
Les palais de la République,
on en parle souvent...
-C'est tout ce qui va autour,
le fait d'avoir énormément
d'administrateurs,
des huissiers...
-Des fonctionnaires ?
-Voilà, qui sont là
pour nous aider,
et finalement,
de constater
la quantité de personnes
qui sont là pour nous aider,
pour nous rendre la vie
la plus facile possible
et notre exercice
le plus aisé possible,
ça m'a évidemment interpellée.
Jusqu'ici,
que ce soit dans l'espace syndical
ou l'espace associatif,
quand on avait besoin
de quelque chose,
c'était à nous de le faire,
à 100 %,
avec des bouts de ficelle,
enfoncer des portes.
Surtout qu'on ne voulait pas
de nous,
forcément, là où on allait.
Fallait y aller.
-Le revers de l'engagement,
c'est qu'on devient une cible
et les attaques
sont parfois éloignées
du terrain politique.
Le 15 octobre 2022,
vous avez découvert
un message posté sur Twitter
par Gilbert Collard qui a utilisé
une photo de vous dans l'hémicycle,
prenant la parole,
accompagnée de ce texte.
Comment avez-vous réagi ?
-J'ai utilisé beaucoup de gros mots,
soyons honnête...
-Donc, de la colère ?
-...quand j'ai découvert ça.
Et puis surtout, ça a réveillé
une autre colère.
Au-delà de ma personne,
c'est pas grave en soi,
c'est tout le mépris
qu'il y avait derrière,
le mépris de classe,
le mépris sexiste,
grossophobe...
Vraiment, tout le mépris
qui venait me dire, tout simplement,
que je n'avais pas ma place
dans l'hémicycle,
et qui disait aux gens
qui, d'une manière ou d'une autre,
peuvent s'identifier et se dire
"moi aussi, je peux être
à cette place-là un jour",
eh bien, dans ce tweet,
Gilbert Collard venait leur dire
qu'ils n'avaient pas leur place.
Ca, c'est d'une violence extrême.
-La violence, ça a été aussi
des messages
que vous avez reçus après ?
-Des messages...
...tous aussi dégueus
les uns que les autres.
-Vous étiez préparée ?
-Des menaces de viol,
de meurtre...
Des avis, évidemment,
sur non pas ce que je suis
ou ce que je représente,
mais qui je suis
et ce que je devrais faire
de mon argent
et de mon temps...
-Vous étiez préparée
à cette forme de violence
qui peut exister en politique ?
-Honnêtement, non.
Ce n'est pas ma façon de faire.
Je ne suis jamais
dans l'attaque ad hominem,
et encore moins sur le physique
des gens.
Donc, bon...
-On termine. C'est l'heure
de notre petit quiz.
Le principe :
je vais commencer une phrase,
vous allez la compléter.
-OK.
-On y va.
"Depuis que je suis députée,
"mes anciens collègues
"de la plate-forme téléphonique
pensent..."
-"Qu'on ne se voit pas assez."
-Ah !
-Pas assez, c'est sûr.
-Vous n'arrivez pas
à les voir ?
-J'en ai revu quelques-uns,
des vrais amis,
mais c'est compliqué.
-"Tout s'arrange
quand tu comprends..."
-"Que t'es pas tout seul."
-Parce qu'au début,
vous vous sentiez un peu seul ?
-Ben, en fait, collectivement,
on arrive
à faire tellement plus de choses,
que ce soit au sein
de nos groupes politiques,
en transpartisan ou...
Vraiment...
C'est assez fabuleux.
-"Ce qui me manque le plus
depuis que je suis députée."
-Du temps.
-Du temps ?
Pour faire ?
-Pour voir mon mari,
pour faire un peu de sport,
pour ne pas faire de politique,
et pour faire de la politique.
Il me faudrait
des journées de 50 heures.
-Pour conclure,
vous disiez vouloir changer la loi,
mais vous êtes dans l'opposition.
Vous ne changez pas vraiment la loi.
Finalement, vous ne vous dites pas
que vous auriez été plus utile
en restant syndicaliste ?
-Non, je ne me dis pas ça.
-Vous avez trouvé
une autre utilité ?
-D'autres façons
d'exercer mon mandat,
parce qu'on travaille
à construire des lois
de façon transpartisane aussi,
et qu'il y a d'autres façons
que d'apporter un texte tout fait,
il y a aussi d'aider
à la construction
du texte, et on peut déjà apporter
sa pierre, d'une part,
par les amendements et en amont,
mais il y a aussi le fait
de pouvoir faire changer
des petites choses par-ci par-là,
parce que j'ai un mandat,
une écharpe tricolore,
parce que, quand on appelle
n'importe qui en disant
"madame la députée",
ça fait changer les choses,
et puis parce qu'on continue
à construire
un Parlement plus à gauche,
et peut-être
qu'à la prochaine élection...
-Merci, Ségolène Amiot,
d'être venue nous voir.
-Avec plaisir.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...